je me détends toi
président depuis dix mois
c'est l'une des voix de droite du
gouvernement on a un débat au parlement
qui tombe là le 4 avril c'est à dire en
plein milieu du séjour prévisionnel et
je lui dois représenter gouvernement
pour répondre aux parlementaires un
bourguignon sous les ors de la
république
il faut pas s'arrêter à ça on est là
pour travailler on n'est pas là pour
juste rester des étoiles dans les yeux
des paillettes qui tranche avec la
lourdeur des dossiers prison a publié
sur le champ international déploie une
énergie considérable et puis avec jean
yves le drian et bien nous appartient le
mettre en musique tout cela je suis
souvent un peu en précurseur aussi pour
préparer en amont un certain nombre de
rendez vous quel est le secret de cette
valeur montante de la génération macron
sachez qu'il fait une promotion absolue
des terroirs de bourgogne de nos climats
etc
et puis et puis fait un très bon boulot
il est très respecté on le voit quand on
se rend à l'étranger et on sent tout de
suite
on arrive que ses homologues apprécié
l'homme nous avons passé trois jours aux
côtés de jean baptiste lemoyne trois
jours pour comprendre celui qui est
devenu le numéro deux du quai d'orsay
voir l'endroit où l'on travaille au l'on
reçoit des délégations
on a toujours naturellement les drapeaux
lorsqu'une délégation étrangère vient on
met le drapeau de son pays également
vous reconnaissez sûrement la marianne
de l'yonne à l'éffigie de christine
lowry c'est le genre sentimental
jean-baptiste lemoyne le genre à
conserver les souvenirs de sa région
dont son bureau parisien de la saint
vincent
et puis il ya un élément qui me suis
toujours que j'avais au sénat une pièce
d'échec un seul homme avait été remis
par des élèves du pôle formation
d'auxerre de la maison de l'entreprise
je me suis attaché c'est toujours sur le
bureau à proximité chez lui on ne voit
d'abord que le visage poupon les
sourires de gentil garçon
le vol pour erevan jeudi 6 10 aux heures
où du 14 heures le décollage de paris
13h40 à 13h45 d'accord non mais c'était
pour voir si fois qu'elle ait quelque
chose mais son entourage est unanime
jean-baptiste lemoyne est un beau
travail qui ne s'arrête jamais 11 avril
en effet moi j'la l'agenda du ministre
ne s'est pas confirmée je ne sais pas
s'il a une méthode c'est qu'il fait
beaucoup de choses il veut faire
beaucoup de choses et que c'est en
perpétuel mouvement
bien plus que le précédent beaucoup plus
car précédent alors vous savez que cette
mappemonde a une particularité c'est
qu'on y voit l'atce la résidence de
françois mitterrand à l'époque mais on y
voit aussi vézelay et donc lionne et la
bourgogne sont là monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui c'est
la concrétisation ou demain sans doute
d'une volonté que le chef de l'état
avait annoncé il ya un an déjà
pour me dire contraire tout à fait le 17
mai à 40 ans le voilà en première ligne
sans les questions de commerce extérieur
tout rester et francophonie
on est au coeur de ce qu'ils touchent le
quotidien des français la scolarisation
par exemple des français établis hors de
france
on est également au coeur de leur
quotidien à travers les métiers
artisanaux ont fait la promotion de la
gastronomie française donc tout ça ce
sont ce sont les hôtels des restaurants
qui font vivre nos territoires ruraux
il ya du pain sur la planche mais quelle
formidable espoir et quelle formidable
espérance alors on se retrousse les
manches on y va ensemble un poste qui
oblige ce père de deux enfants à faire
des sacrifices
on se console avec la technologie avec
les watts ape de facetime qui permettent
de garder le contact avec les enfants
mais c'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où
on m'appelle papa téléphone je me rends
compte que il ya malheureusement ça va
ça induit des sacrifices familiaux
jean baptiste le mois dès le premier élu
de droite à avoir rallié emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui à ce sacrifice il le fait il
ya un an alors que le bâton les
républicains tangue en pleine affaire
fillon jean baptiste lemoyne claque la
porte de son parti et par soutenir le
futur président
[Musique]
le 2 mars et macron présente son projet
présidentielle moi je me suis je suis
dans mon bureau sénat et je regarde ça à
la télé il a je me dis et il m'arrive
les mots de la bouche
si tu es honnête avec toi même sa
démarche est intéressante et elle peut
être un pari réussi
le 21 juin 2017 jean baptiste lemoyne
intègre le deuxième gouvernement
d'édouard physique
sa mission secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères je savais que la décision que
je prenais d'apporter mon soutien le
vaqueront me vaudrait énormément de
remarques de critiques voire d' insulte
mais quand on est bien dans sa tête ça
vous savez ça vous à tapas donc vous
laisser les chiens aboient la caravane
passe
paria à droite devrait bien qu'elle
doive être conviés dans le saint des
saints sauf erreur le ministre tisse sa
toile chez les marcheurs démarche a
séduit par son audace et son sens
politique mois de l'image que j'ai de
jean baptiste est d'abord celui du
courage de ses convictions il a sans
doute fait le constat avant d'autres que
les clivages gauche droite était quelque
chose qui s'amenuise est et qu'il
fallait sans doute sortir de ce clivage
un peu artificiel et il suffit et
conviction
[Musique]
c'est que depuis le début du mandat
voilà après beaucoup de jean-baptiste
lemoyne serait vrai qu'ils ont nouveau
chouchou des marcheurs dans l'yonne
marie-louise sport et andré villiers
l'ont côtoyé pendant vingt ans dans les
rangs de la droite
pour jean-baptiste lemoyne est avant
tout un bon stratège
je pense qu'il fait partie de ces jeunes
qui cherchent à trouver une voie
meilleur pour remettre sur les rails le
pays
donc je lui pardonne d'avoir rejoint
d'autant plus qu'il fait une belle
carrière et qu' il est normal à son âge
qu'on ait envie de faire un bon parcours
il ya parfois des positionnements qui
surprennent le fait que jean baptiste
lemoyne et fait ses armes auprès de jean
françois copé
donc quelqu'un qui appartenait à cette
droite quand même très affirmée dont il
s'est affranchi est passé auprès de
françois fillon puis ensuite alain juppé
tour franchir le rubicon et rejoindre
emmanuel macron donc moi j'y vois une
envie de participer à la vie à la vie
politique de son pays de ne pas perdre
de temps lui loin des guéguerres
politiques seraient du côté des gens du
concret ce jour-là à matignon la france
et le luxembourg signent des accords
historiques
aujourd'hui c'est le sait le jour j on a
préparé sa en amont et puis je crois que
tout va bien se passer
des semaines de tractations en coulisses
pour aboutir à cette signature
il ya un certain nombre de défis en
commun sur lesquels au début pouvoirs
des différentes approches
il ya eu d'acte et le fait d'augmenter
le nombre de trains et de rotations
entre la lorraine et le luxembourg
parce que cent mille français vont
travailler au luxembourg et ça pose de
gros problèmes de mobilité et la volonté
des deux gouvernements comme celle des
élus locaux c'est trouver des solutions
concrètes à cette situation de faire en
sorte que la circulation soit plus
fluide depuis un peu plus de dix mois
que je travaille avec jean baptiste je
ne peux que me réjouir de son
enthousiasme de sa force de travail
c'est pas le plus spectaculaire des
postes du gouvernement parce que c'est
un poste qui exige de bouger de bouger
d'expliquer ce qui se passe en france à
nos interlocuteurs étrangers d'être
capable aussi de nourrir l'action du
gouvernement avec les retours de
l'extérieur ça existe beaucoup beaucoup
de disponibilité la diplomatie un
travail de l'ombre et de longue haleine
une tâche parfois ingrate qui n'entame
pas l'enthousiasmé du jeune ministre
je dois dire que
je kiffe c'est très intéressant il ya
vingt ans je m'étais dit que je voulais
présenter les concours élite et d'orsay
pour être diplomate
tout ça pour dire qu'il ya toujours un
fil dans la vie que ce fils faut jamais
le perdre et que c'est ça qui fait que
vous êtes en accord avec vous même et
est donc bien dans vos baskets
certains critiquent seul chemin parfois
tortueux jean-baptiste lemoyne continue
de tracer sa route à sa façon